hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's sister location now earlier
today
Scott released a patch for the game that
involved night four because apparently
the spring-locks section was obscenely
difficult but not for me because I beat
it pre patch and even said in the patch
notes that I get bragging rights he
didn't call me out specifically but I
know that I was in his heart when he was
thinking about it so I get to keep my
crown upon my head and I still as smelly
and his tarnish and is slightly sweaty
as it might be I get to keep my glorious
crown and continue to call myself the
king of five nights at Freddy's sorry
did I now say that right look King Wow
five nights at Freddy's so I get to be a
little proud of that but I'm sure that
my pride will be ripped from my chest as
soon as I go into Fox's area because I'm
pretty sure there's something new
waiting for me I bet it is not gonna be
farty
[Music]
I don't hear nothing which is usually a
bad sign I mean usually it's a good sign
but
[Music]
is there no one here I guess we're just
done oh my god I don't like that all
parts and service great job reaching
parts and service circus baby has been
deactivated for an unknown reason it's
your job to make sure she is
structurally stable and secured to the
conveyor our technicians will take it
from there remember how I said I could
pretend baby
the cameras are watching I must be
careful not to move something bad
happened yesterday something bad always
happens I don't want it to happen again
there is something bad
inside of me I'm broken I can't be fixed
I'm going to be taken to the scooping
room soon but it's not going to fix
what's wrong with me what is bad is
always left behind will you help me I
want you to say what is good so the rest
can be destroyed and it never recovered
but you must be careful
Melora is here in the room with us but
laura will not return to her stage
Valera will not return to her body you
must be careful you must remain calm
and listen to my voice there is a button
on my cheek you must find it and press
it oh god there's a passcode that you
must enter before you can retrieve me
enter the code carefully
[Music]
seven one seven four four five seven two
nine three good a hat should have open
take the card that you find inside now
you must turn back I will guide you
through fun time auditorium so you can
reach the scooping room when you are
there I want you to destroy this body
put the card into your handheld device
and I can continue to speak to you now
press the green button to your left this
will send me to the scooping
[Music]
you must follow my instruction a fun
time auditorium Valora is going to
follow you she will try to catch you
okay I will help you avoid her she will
not follow you inside the scoping room
she is afraid okay yeah she was just
there but why did you kidnap me was that
the good as a bad okay alrighty then I
guess go forward stop go forward and
left
[Music]
keep going why is it so wet okay go
forward and left go forward you are
almost there stop she is right in front
of you don't hmm he's here to help
Valera he is not here to hurt us Hey
Melora he is here to help us but if i
flash my beacon right now go forward
again but laura is behind you she is
afraid of this grouping room she will
not follow you warning you've entered a
highly dangerous area you have entered
from maintenance hatch one be reserved
for cleaning and repair of the scooper
entering this side of the room is
strictly prohibited by unauthorized
personnel hey wait a minute
it is that below as bothering the
scooping room now it is fun time foxy
has already been here today
fun time Freddy has
been here today but Laura has already
been here today groveling his baby has
already been here today I've been out
before but they always put me back they
always put us back inside there's
nowhere for us to hide here there is
nowhere to go hey I see you but if we
looked like you then we could hide yeh
if we look like you then we would have
somewhere to go
hey the scooper only hurts for a moment
[Music]
so jeez I got scooped Oh God
oh no I knew something was bad I knew it
was wrong
let me come see your wonderful children
jeez so I might my dad except what is it
oh geez
[Music]
oh god what is that oh god oh hey
handsome how you doing there oh that's
ah hi baby
wouldn't you enjoying my body is very no
that's not the end no I know it's not
the end I know that's not the end
there's no way in hell that was the end
okay so I'm gonna get through these I'm
gonna get through these credits but you
know I might as well take this moment to
say that this game is phenomenal I love
it and a lot of people probably are like
comparing it to the old five nights at
freddys but I think this is exactly what
the series needed a paradigm shift and
what it is while still keeping the creep
universe that it's in I think it
captured like the essence and the feel
of five nights at Freddy's as opposed to
anything else you know and the other
ones trying to replicate the formula but
this one broke the mold and yet kept the
feel of it which is wonderful
but this is not done Scott I know you I
know this it doesn't end in the fifth
night I know that no no get out of here
Oh get out of here you get out of here
no way no no no I'm not happening nope
nothing that's no that's a big no okay
so there's more to this and I'm gonna
explore and try to find it so I'll be
right I have a funny feeling it has to
do with those death minigames because
there's probably a way if you ration
your cupcakes correctly and assign the
cupcake to the right child because some
cupcakes like some kids only had one
cupcake some kids have multiple cupcakes
so there's a way to do it so that
there's more oh I get extras now I see I
got one star I know there's more
Scot Stephanie Oh baby and her babies oh
oh that's what they were they look like
little little uh animation drawing
figurines you know mannequins oh look at
that they almost look adorable oh she's
beautiful
Oh CeCe oh man why so many why her this
is why so many wars and so many wires oh
it's so cute oh not at all that's so
weird
okay so there's got to be something here
because this one
I see wires for feet and we kind of saw
it in the reflection so this is like the
this is the version of the endoskeleton
it's it like the other animatronics were
had endoskeletons and that's what they
were and they had shells so these ones
when they get scooped they get this
stuff scooped out of them and that's
apparently what happens there and in the
animatronics or in the in the
spring-trap section this animatronic was
on the right because they had to be
looking at Bowl or had to be pulled over
to the left to be scooped you know how
it was so you were looking at it from
this angle which meant you were on the
right side of the room so there's
something over there oh and Freddie Oh
Freddie you've looked better Freddie oh
okay see what's in there what's in the
private room so what happens what
happens if when you're walking through
you go right like instead of going left
every time she says left you go forward
and right instead what if you do that
what if that happens that's an
interesting thing okay
I'm gonna try that let's go let's do
that oh man
that's not a blueprint that's it
horrifying okay so I just noticed
something there's a keypad right here
and baby gave a very specific string of
numbers I can't remember what it was it
was seven one seven something something
something but there's a keypad there so
there can't be entirely out of the
question to try to input that number
there's another keypad right here so
maybe I got to input them on all the
keypads or something I don't know maybe
greatest now let's check on funtime Fox
there's got to be a reason there's
keypads right there's got to be a reason
hey don't mention it wait is your job to
make sure she is stable and secured to
the conveyor our technicians will take
it from there
oh I see it now how did I not see that
how did I not see that oh oh
different oh is the code random or is
that just is it two separate codes it
might be it might be just random numbers
okay go forward
[Music]
was not correct
okay so there's got to be okay there's
got to be something else I'm exploring a
lot of different options here I don't
think I'm gonna get it in this episode
I'm gonna try to figure this out but I'm
gonna do one more thing I'm gonna try to
get to the minigame now which just
involves me dying and then I'm gonna
figure out a way to beat it I'm gonna
see if you can like stack the cupcakes
together there we go I got the game okay
so it's gotta be something to do with
this game right so there's a way maybe
to ration out freaking things it's gotta
be away okay so okay so they're they're
fed so maybe it's like using the right
ones in the right location cuz like this
triplet here could be taken care of by
the green one oh [ __ ] god dammit what
okay so the shotgun blast this kid needs
three I think is what that damn it
fudge fudge fudge Futaba fudge fudge
fuzz fuzz but there is no way that that
is going to work it is a load of
[ __ ] and I hate it a lot damn it
okay so so I almost got all of them but
it's just like it's like I didn't get
all of them I think if there might be a
way if I jump over the cupcake and get
two and then come back for the triple
one and then ah man I got to get to in
the kid and then three the shotgun oh
it's just convoluted it might be
possible it might be possible you must
follow my instructions in auditorium
[Music]
okay that's progress holy [ __ ] I haven't
been able to do anything oh so I made a
mistake before I before oh I thought I
couldn't do that I went forward and then
forward and right I just needed to go
forward and right immediately after you
go out that door you hit W and D
immediately and Bank for that but it
said access denied so there's something
I need somewhere in the game to get
through that private room I still think
it has to do with the mini game but I
need to find a better way to die that
sounds horrible but I need to find a
better way to die repeatedly so that I
can get the mini game if foxy was here
in that room that would make it so much
easier but I do not have that right now
so I've been trying for a while so I
think I'm out of time for this episode
here but that is progress so you need
something in the game I believe there's
got to be a way to get the cupcakes to
every kid in the game like I'm pretty
sure it has to do with using like the
cupcakes in the right place where
there's staggered ones you get those
where there's ones alone you get those
when there's spread ones you get those
like there's an option to do it because
you get four blue one
and there's like to spread zones of
three of them and you can definitely hit
those there's three green ones and
there's definitely lines of guys in a
row that you can definitely hit so there
are options to do that you just have to
find the right one and then jump over
the cupcakes so that you run over and
get the right ones at the right time to
do everything that you need to do first
before you get all the cupcakes so I
don't know how long that's gonna take so
imma take care of that in the next
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching that is my hypothesis let me
know if there's anything that I should
do differently before I do the next
video so as soon as this one goes up
write down the comments below if there's
anything else you think I should do but
I think I'm on the right track here I
just need more time to get it done so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]